l tutti ragazzi è pervenuto che sono
video sono spa vi j
prima di cominciare volevo dirvi che se
i miei capelli vi sembrano arrow state
tranquilli perché di horror oggi c'è
un'altra cosa ed è a honey la serie che
voglio iniziare oggi è un gioco che mi
avevo giocato circa cinque anni fa non
mi ricordo più il gioco cioè nel senso
mi ricordo che una mazza e l'altro
giorno ci pensavo ricevo minchiate figo
che era honey anche se non mi ricordo
niente ma si dai facciamo ci gameplay
quindi new game è sbagliato da qual è il
nome del protagonista
allora che bello che i rossi
questo è un nome regalo incazzerà
hiroshi testicolo ragazzi il nome del
nostro personaggio c'è mica sono troppo
contento ne avevo iniziato perché è
bellissimo il ve lo assicuro vi
divertirete un sacco abbiamo sentito le
voci di una villa fuori città
dicono che sia abitata da un mostro cioè
la parte ovviamente che cosa fai sentire
le voci così ma vai a controllare ma
certo è molto più carina all'interno
mica no mica non è questa amica è così
vabbè sono io qui fa davvero freddo
takeshi lei
usciamo di qua cosa c'è che non va
takeshi hai paura
cos'era ei usciamo dico altro questa
nostra dire altro sa di software bravo a
takeshi testicolo così stupido non è
possibile che i mostri esistano è
scientificamente impossibile bravo
testicolo fai valere il tuo nome e
testicolo non preoccuparti takeshi
testicolo sano tra cavare stai attento
vai tranquillo zio
adesso posso giacomo a figo certo che la
casa abbandonata infestata non mostri si
rompono le cose ma certo non è pura
controllare mi sembrava un piatto c'è un
piatto rotto a te ampia come bellissima
ho trovato l'oggetto scheggia di piatto
questo mi chiamo ne faccio della
scheggia di un piatto spiega va beh
torniamo da takeshi che così si ripiglia
che povero ragazzo
non ha capito che schifezza e merda che
sono andati a casa che c'ha puntata di
social face e ragazzi che poi non si è
sentito né ancora al vedete qua dentro
ragazzi non si apre ma quale meglio nel
solco più contento che non sia a provare
al meglio usi non si aprono si apre
niente ragazzino a casa e va bene non si
apre cosa devo fare se non si aprono le
cose di qua non si sa ma si apre
qualcosa e sto gioco che lo facciamo di
sopra le sto punto bello mi piace
l'ambientazione bella la disegnavo
meglio io zio credito la porta è chiusa
ragazzi si apre qualcosa in soggiorno mi
dovete prendere per il culo tempini
questo sia per ragazzi ragazzuoli
paranormal armadio e sono fa vj vengo in
pace o takeshi pronta deficiente ecco
dove ripartirà scondi nell'armadio
rincoglionito trema perché sei tremando
zio che è successo
hai visto il nostro takeshi treno sto
tizio qua mi piaccia un dialogo che
incredibile non sono gli altri sono
scommetto che trema vaio p riguarda
incredibile è 3 ma lasciate le macchine
sociale impostato su vibrazione sto
cristiano va bene dai ragazzi usciamo 3
ma pure tranquillo che me ne sto andando
è per carità di dio
ecco la parte che va bè mi chiama sia
fai qualcosa del tutto chiuso tutto grey
cat allora che doveva nel castello letto
eletto sottomettono
chiave della biblioteca perfetto mi che
grazie takeshi senza al tuo aiuto non ce
l'avrei mai fatta e zio grazie mille
ma devo provare tutte le porte finché
non trova biblioteca li mortacci mia a
questa andava ancora provata prima
scusate la kia è così perfetto niente
ottonata biblioteca fantasma che mi
salva e ragazzi qualunque coso lì in
realtà dovrebbe essere a ogni è però c'è
un muro non c'è niente è andato di qua
cos'è entrato nel muro perché al tipo oh
guarda o trovare il libro di harry
potter ragazzi che lo scopo della
biblioteca questo che ne so dove li
metti i libri della rowling zio abitare
questo libro d'aral ho trovato l'oggetto
chiave della camera le chiavi della
camera da letto chiave della camera da
letto dove dove sta la camera da letto
che ne so io chi cazzo ci oggi ma la tua
amica 6 sfruttato aiuto aiuto vi
stuprata da dove cazzo è sfruttato da
dove non si sa perché tema fa il culo
dai mi chiama laddove vi sia il sito
madame [ __ ] che non volevo salvato
o ragazzi ricordatevi che devo salvare
sempre io prendo sta roba mi mi segue in
automatico
sì mi sapeva fun cool ma quanto sei
bello madonna va avanti e bmw tutti
vorrebbero seguente mica ce la faccia di
brad pitt lo chiamano è aperto da tempo
[ __ ]
non l'ho [ __ ] orcadi quella la
gramigna quanto è difficile che poi
magari mi ricordo che in teoria puoi
anche dribblarlo sto tizio series tipo
nome non ci provo lasciamo perdere
dove devo andare mi spiegate che non lo
so perché vado a chiudermi sempre nelle
stanze dove non posso uscire ma al cuore
ma che cazzo di sopra di tutto
nell'armadio vai vai veloce
ah già è vero che si deve incidere
allarmati non so riparla questa cosa mi
chiudo nell'armadio è uscito sei brutto
deficiente quanto sei prodotta tof
ottobre migliaia grippare il cugino ce
l'ho fatta e che è sta roba testicolo
trovato l'oggetto fazzoletto e sarà vita
che è citato si stava pure cagano
addosso quindi mi sa che sei pulito pure
al culo perfetto ce l'ho fatta non so
come a scappare dal team ma ve lo
ricordavo che devo fidarmi nell'armadio
perché un paio di rob e me ne ricordo
però quasi niente che si va bene così
così ho trovato la chiave della camera
da letto e chiavi della camera è questa
qua
usate la chiave della canaletta permesso
a un suo perché di esistere sulla stanza
perché questo è bianco c'è qualcosa qua
ragazzi per forza e più bianco sul
pavimento
ho spinto letto mica sono forte era
finto serviva solo spingere il letto ma
ho capito che adesso ce ne sta un altro
cielo devo andare a comprare da ikea e
portarlo qui perfetta urbana piega
ragazzi ma l'altro portano la mano che
ho provato ad aprirla questa quinta ha
infatti si apre mie se ci trova un altro
mio amico nell'armadio minchia manco
narnia no non poi mi sono chiuso io
perfetto ma non ci sono ok niente falso
allarme scherzava media gazzella porta
finta voglio capire l'utilità di una
porta finta anno spiega melo adesso non
lo spieghi dunque non ho capito nella
camera devo fare qualcosa
chi è che arrivi spostato al letto io le
cose le si posto come sa già che ci
stava il buco che niente quindi ho
sbagliato io a dove entrarci spiegatemi
perché un buco nel pavimento dovrebbe
portarmi in una stanza con un pianoforte
spiegatemi questa cosa è per me posso
suonare qualcosa io che sono capacissimo
che ascolto tutto martin garics il frate
non l'hai detto la tua ragazza che
quando al maestro non deve suonare
pianoforte che macchia tutto noi devo
fare qualcosa in sostanza parti guardare
il pianoforte
oddio è una casa più bella a cassaforte
ma su assalito armadi come ho fatto a
trovarla c'ho azzeccato zio usciamo
ragazzi non c'è nient'altro porta aperta
a quindi siamo a sbloccato la porta
adesso o perfetto
devo tipo pulire il pianoforte con
questo no credevo di farlo col
fazzoletto invece niente
dopo un cazzo sei uscito ma questo è
pazzo ma spiegatemi non mi vedo io sto
gioco non lo capisco da dove è uscito da
google deretano dado da dove non c'è
niente vabbè non ho capito se cosa un
serio su campi dove vado dove vado ad
elevato l'armadio la radio radio ma di
come la gente armadio e tra baganza
famiglia media che rassicuri forse no
forse no se non clicchi niente rimane
così ragazze rimane in nero ok prefetto
l'ansia fino all'ultimo che se esci
mentre lui ancora dentro la stanza ci
crepi fantastico ci sarà qualcosa che
devo trovare di qua sicuro tipo nel
cesso tutto io so tutto di senza neanche
ricordarmi le sole cose hai trovato
l'oggetto cacciavite a stella in una
vasca da bagno un cacciavite a stella
che cosa mi piaci fa portante ed aver
trovato un cacciavite che invece a
qualcuno in sostanza all'inizio che non
ho ben capito chi fosse però ansia
perché questa purtroppo oggetto sapone
sapone piemontese ne chiese al cesso m
giusto avere lui semicalvo addosso
giustamente corro qua a ok e prova a
pulire il pianoforte giusto devo usare
il sapone per forza per pulirlo perché
se no è impossibile
cioè non so cos'altro fare ha stupito
versi il sapone sul fazzoletto a sapore
più fazzoletto che perfetto e mastro
lindo fa il suo dovere ho pulito il
pianoforte col fazzoletto bravo zio
traguardo della vita fratello 9 41 alla
cassaforte giusto 941 perché sul
pianoforte dovresti scrivere il codice
della cassaforte spiega e per questo
sono quattro e che ne so 941 anno 09 41
come sapete già tutti la classe non è
vacca cos'è che c'eravate entrati di
sottrarre i soldi chiave della camera da
letto del bambino quale bambino spiega
miccoli colori non è un bambino come mi
segue da un po grosso per essere un
bambino se ti riferisci a lui e poi sono
un uso lo sai camera del bambino questa
usata chiaro che culo la prima volta che
ho provato la causata da chiara la
chiave era che il mio italiano
la chiave alla eletto chi è questa non
seriamente mica a quelli prima testicolo
a ciao zia posso farti una domanda molto
semplice io che ci ho messo un anno e
mezzo ed entra qua dentro come cazzo hai
fatto che non c'è rimanga chiave dove
sono gli altri guardano saranno le altre
porte chiuse e non si sa come siano
entrati e per carità non ne ho idea ci
siamo separati perché spiega per quale
motivo ha davvero vieni con me lo
aspetto qui alieni come ti porterò
lontano perché non andrò in giro per
quello per questa villa con quel mostro
là fuori
ok che te devo dire stai qua fa il cazzo
che vuoi brutta stronza io che volevo
guadagnarmi la passerà così che non
possono anche fare il galantuomo che
niente franson anche nei giochi horror
france non voleva essere gentile che
cazzo ne sta roba è una roba la sopa
dell'ospitale sedi a dar forza
ok perfetto e fatemi salvare non si sa
mai che entra il tipo che deve saltare
addosso a qualcuno salta addosso a lei
io non ne voglio sapere ho trovato
l'oggetto combustibile dell'accendino
posso cortesemente sapere di chi
accendino stai parlando che non
accennino io latifah poi la lascio lì
chissenefrega
va bene così ero convintissimo che fosse
chiusa st forma non avevo già approvata
non era chiusa la porta è chiusa ok ma è
sono aperte da sole le porte così hanno
aperto st porta per poi dirmi che c'era
un'altra porta chiusa fantastica
le cose scopro le cose sono entrato
anch'io dentro un muro fantastica questa
cosa non l'avevo capito dorado di qua ok
fermi fermi felice invece direi che
posso concludere qui il primo episodio
di aoni perché io sono una persona che
conclude sempre nei momenti migliori
avete visto il primo episodio che era un
po per capire la storia mettiamola così
ma da adesso in avanti
lo vedrete nei prossimi episodi sarà una
roba troppo [ __ ] vi dovete far capire se
volete che la continui alla serie dove
scrivere continua di sotto se volete
spero che vi sia per cento ragazzi cosa
è servito per sull'argomento non mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook che
venivi nota la notizia ne sono serviti
scrittrici vi diamo un prossimo video
[Musica]